we're at blizzcon we're hyped up on
overwatch juice I'm Andy I'm Eric oh man
we just put the new heroes that they
announced this morning at the holistic
on opening ceremonies I played me and
let me tell you about me all right do it
she throws up ice walls all right and
when we were defending a point beyond me
Japan map I Nomura and more there's that
main entrance right and usually Ryan
Hart comes in there with the shield and
you're like or I just wait to accompany
me I was like no boom put up put up a
nice wall put up another eyes all just
kept them at bay out there it was so
clutch and even though my score wasn't
that good because I don't think like it
has a metric for counting on that um I
feel like I really had an impact on that
on the game and also her freeze ray was
really good i could run around and
freeze people and then shoot a
projectile yeah that one works the way
like if the longer you hold down the
freeze like you will actually freeze the
character yeah you can set up a self
glacier around yourself like a little
ice ice block ice block and then you
heal up which is really good for point
defense this is a very good defense
character I love playing sir yeah and
her alt you used one time pretty
effectively TN and afros everyone on the
capture points without like I think
someone else what Reaper came up and
swept up so that was kind of cool do
yeah it was awesome I'm really in love
with these new characters what did you
put I played Ginji who turns out to be
hand Zoe's brother oh so he has a
like-kind of like his wall his like
space is like the wall kind of climb
like hands oh so I was using that to
flank around on hina Mora and I was
getting in the base just totally
frustrating there to bash tunes and he's
pretty cool so his main left-click
ability is like he throws ninja stars
that's his kind of like ranged attack
you can do right-click which will throw
three at a time I think the stock was 24
and then you can reload them he has a
deflect ability which is like his e and
so like if you see a projectile coming
and deflect it back at them if you can
time it damn
yeah and his shift is pretty good too is
like a dashboard and if you dashboard
through someone it does like a dot I
believe so it's like even more damage
and it's good for like Reinhart you just
dash through them and then like he's
disoriented and then you just throw new
stars as backward from alien and it's
all super fun it just basically Roy's
out his sword and you just go to town
and like shift around and just like
slice people up i got like a triple kill
him and I was awesome and I think you
played the last new character diva did
tell me about her so I play around with
diva and we were attacking and you were
just talking about man attacking on the
same map and we won both rounds and the
second time I think diva played such a
big role in it I never died and I got
the most eliminations and I'm that great
at the game her the key to her is she
plays exactly like a titanfall character
um if you're familiar with that at all
she's in a mech but if you die you just
pop out and then you're on foot but you
only have like 150 health and like one
pistol but you can just run around and
then wait for a recharge and you can
call down another mech after you right
and that's well that's different than
your cue ok that's it is mapped q um but
it doesn't actually do anything just
call down / mech and then you're back in
your suit with unlimited ammo like 500
health and then what you can do is stop
projectiles with E and it stops you from
firing button stops all incoming
projectiles for a limited time and then
you can actually jump away using like a
boost jet that jumps you forward yeah
that's your shift right it's a [ __ ] yeah
like a booster movie a little bit sprint
boost like job like and you can even
catch some good air with it um what's
amazing with her alt though is you
basically ditch your suit so like what I
did is I i sent my suit in to the
capture point and I jumped out and then
my suit exploded on the capture point
killed all these people and I called
down a new suit immediately that's
insane so it's like whatever I don't
know but it was such a good alt and I
was like oh here we go yeah sorry you
sounds like one of those really strong
combo ones like maybe it may freeze them
and then you send the suit in and she
blow them all up yeah I have great time
with both of those new characters like I
can't believe how different they are
than the other ones and I mean it is
totally a titanfall character like it's
totally inspired by john-paul yeah to
the T what's great but it looks more
like ghost in the shell is that cool
boys in the shell field
yeah and that's awesome so you know we
got to try out the three characters this
is our little rundown on it overwatch
coming to three platforms oh my next
year I think spring 2013 pc xbox one ps4
on looking forward to it man dude can't
wait
[Music]
you